2013 is here guys it's a new year
there's new things that can be done new
fun things that you can do you can go
find a job you can go build something
you can maybe start a relationship or
make a new friend but whatever you do
don't see Texas Chainsaw 3d this is the
first weekend in January guys and this
is my first review of a movie in 2013
congratulations Texas Chainsaw 3d that's
all you have going for you if you can't
tell I'd like to keep this as big as
possible this movie's horrible it's
awful real quick this movie's actually a
sequel to the original film from the
1970s indeed it is in this movie it
starts off in the beginning back in the
70s you see the townspeople immediately
come to the house where Leatherface was
because of reports from the one woman
who escaped all these local townspeople
burn the house down because they're so
upset these people they all burn the
house down and kill all other faces
family but of course Leatherface escapes
as does one baby yes a baby escapes this
place she's adopted by these two Hicks
who just so happened to be there and
discover her she grows up to be a slutty
porn star who's dating Trey Songz and
when her grandma dies she apparently
somehow knew exactly where she was and
left that house to her so her and her
friends decide to go out to that house
and what do you know the other face is
still in the basement and stuff starts
happening I'm sorry if any of you
thought this movie was going to be good
I truly apologize because how could you
have possibly thought this movie was
going to be good look back in history
the first weekend of January for
Hollywood is where they customarily
dumped any type of supernatural thriller
or horror film that's just always awful
past examples include one missed call
the unborn season of the witch The Devil
Inside and now we have Texas Chainsaw 3d
the first weekend in January is where
Hollywood dumps their horror
supernatural thriller cliched Hollywood
garbage it really is it's like exactly
like the stuff that all of these horror
spooks lately have been talking about
like cabin in the woods there literally
is the dumb blonde character who just
walks around with her boobs hanging out
makes jokes gets drunk does drugs
doesn't care about anything walks into
all the obvious
horrible situations and then as soon as
the crap hits the fan she just sobs and
sobs Pete no one does that okay look I
don't care what situation you're in no
one just my neighbors think I'm having
violent intercourse at the moment I'm
sorry
look oh my god this movie was awful ah
it was so terrible guys I'm serious that
just the writing it was just so so dumb
and it was so poorly acted on everyone's
part everyone in this movie was awful it
was directed so bad it was just so awful
it was terrible everyone please I beg
you don't see this movie I know you're
like wow Chris wow this must be awful I
want to go see it don't do not give
these people money they don't deserve
your money if you have a job all right
if your parents give you allowance if
you have any type of income don't give
them to these people they don't deserve
it you deserve your money keep your
money save it for something special
whatever you do don't give these people
money oh my god this movie was awful and
don't even think about telling me that
I'm being too hard because it's some
stupid horror movie and what did I
expect no look this movie truely is
awful like everything about this movie
is awful like it just it's terrible the
only entertaining part of this film is
the opening credits because it recaps
the original film by showing footage
from the original film there's a recap
like like it's like the season premiere
or something and they want to remind you
what happened last time
look I can't even go on to give you an
accurate review without telling you some
spoilers all right I gotta spoil some
things look if you want to see this
movie first off just just don't see it I
am having convulsions I can't not tell
you about some of these stupid things in
this movie number one okay when she
inherits this house and she's there with
her buddy Trey Songz and oh god the guy
comes out with the paperwork and he says
here here's this letter from your
grandma be sure to read it when he
leaves he's like remember read the
letter of course she does not read the
letter until the end of the movie guess
what's in the letter her grandma is like
I just wanted to let you know that in
the basement is your cousin he just
wants to be loved and needs care and he
will take care of you forever seriously
that's how she set him up for the
chainsaw wielding maniac in the basement
who has no idea that he has a cousin hey
grandma
you're pretty done one of the villains
in this movie is actually the mayor of
this town who hates anyone related to
that family and will kill them no matter
what even this random innocent girl he
tries to frickin kill her gets his
friend to try to hit her with a car he
ties her up he beats her up I'm like
really you're how do you become the
mayor of a town with mmm I was seriously
driving home from this movie just
shaking my head as I was walking up the
hallway in my apartment I was just still
thinking about it as soon as the credits
popped up on this movie I was out of
that theater in less than five seconds I
entertained the thought of leaving so
many times but I'm never gonna do that I
will always do my best to review the
film and sit there and just take it and
just take it and just keep taking it
guys tonight I got to tell you it felt
like work let's relieve this review with
this one little thought Hollywood will
you please stop releasing absolute
horrible films every January well you
don't really care at all you just want
to make a quick buck you got Trey Songz
in there because you want to get the
teens in there who like his music you
got all these women with the boobs and
everything and you don't actually ever
see them it's just a whole bunch of
teasing it's just
lastly it's called Texas Chainsaw 3d
that's the official title of this movie
so like apparently unless you have a 3d
TV a 3d blu-ray player when you buy this
movie it's just going to be called Texas
Chainsaw of course you'd have to be dumb
enough to actually buy this movie Texas
Chainsaw 3d gets an F it's a horrible
movie I'm sure will be in my top 10
worst of the year by the end of this
year don't see it I know you just this
is it's a fun review for me to do this
it's just it's so bit it's this movie
has actually made being capable of
speaking
Wow guys that was a wrap I obviously can
I remember the last time I rented that
much about a movie Wow
I'm okay it's all good just don't go see
the movie all right I'm gonna calm down
now I'm gonna have a glass of water and
I'm just going to go to the gym and pump
some iron and you okay that'll be better
all right as always guys if you like
this video you can click right here and
get stuck my next
you